que répondriez vous si je vous demandais
si le nucléaire pollue qu'elle serait
une réponse adéquate à cette question et
maintenant quelle réponse pensez vous
que google fournit lorsque vous lui
demandez si le nucléaire polluent quels
sites google recommande-t-il en priorité
à des milliards d'utilisateurs sur le
sujet de la pollution du nucléaire pour
répondre à cette question je vais vous
présenter les résultats d'une recherche
en navigation privée depuis lausanne en
suisse
le dimanche 14 mars 2021 si vous faites
les mêmes recharge depuis chez vous vous
devriez obtenir des résultats différents
et ça c'est très intéressant du coup je
vous invite à auditer vous même google
[Musique]
pas son résultat de mes recherches de
façon criante chez moi google met
exclusivement en avant un article de la
société française d'énergie nucléaire
qui insiste sur l'absence d'émission des
particules qui contribuent le plus à la
pollution de l'air de l'eau et des
forêts le deuxième l'un lui vient du
réseau sortir du nucléaire
étrangement l'extrait choisi par google
parle de bombe atomique alors que
l'article parle en fait davantage des
déchets nucléaires
le troisième vient lui répond ben non le
nucléaire qui pollue pas alors que la
réponse à la question encadré extraite
du troisième lien répond lui aussi non
qu'en est-il maintenant des autres
moteurs de recherche que disent les
algorithmes les plus influents du monde
à des milliards d'utilisateurs au sujet
de la pollution nucléaire
microsoft bing lui qu un verre c'est en
quelque sorte les priorités il référence
en premier le site sortir du nucléaire
pour orgue qui insiste sur les déchets
radioactifs le second lien lui souligne
que le nucléaire émet beaucoup moins de
gaz à effet de serre que le charbon les
vidéos recommandé elles sont par contre
négatifs sur le nucléaire
s'il ya ou recommande les deux mêmes
sites que bing il le fait dans un ordre
opposé par ailleurs étrangement le
premier lien met en avant la définition
de l'énergie nucléaire plutôt que
l'onglet le nucléaire et l'environnement
rattray un peu plus pertinent pour la
question posée cet onglet souligne par
ailleurs les risques d'utilisation pour
des bombes nucléaires sur cointe parmi
les quatre premiers liens on trouve deux
fois le site sortir du nucléaire point
org avec étrangement les mêmes extraits
le deuxième lien parle des effets sur
les gaz à effet de serre et le quatrième
le lien lui parle des accidents nu
claire et de leurs conséquences
sanitaires et sur la contamination des
sols comme courante
ecocéane mais sortir du nucléaire point
org deux fois en avant parmi les trois
premiers liens avec rob energie.com en
deuxième position chez les dogues togo
on a un quatuor initial fait deux sites
différents qui font du 50 50 avec
alternativement un lien critique du
nucléaire et un lien qui souligne les
avantages sur la pollution de l'air
enfin sur youtube
les recommandations par le tout des
déchets nucléaires notez par ailleurs
que de façon intrigante à l'exception de
youtube
les recherches anglophone base nucléaire
paul août met systématiquement en avant
les faibles émissions en co2 du
nucléaire avec même des onglets qui
souligne que le nucléaire est
probablement l'énergie avec le plus
faible impact sur l'environnement mais
donc est ce que tout ça ça vous
satisfait est ce que les résultats de
recherche vous paraissent robustement
bénéfique au futur de l'humanité
est ce que ce sont les réponses que ses
algorithmes devrait fournir à des
milliards d'utilisateurs
ce que j'aimerais illustré avec ce bref
des moteurs de recherche ce n'est pas
tant si les algorithmes sont bons ou
mauvais malheureusement une analyse de
ces algorithmes demanderait une étude
beaucoup plus poussée et sophistiquée
que ce que je viens de présenter ce sur
quoi j'aimerais insister c'est que ses
algorithmes n'ont rien de neutre en fait
ne peuvent rien avoir de neutre les
utilisateurs veulent que ses algorithmes
met des sites ou des vidéos en avant
plutôt que d'autres ces algorithmes sont
donc contraints de juger ce qui doit
être recommandée ils ne peuvent pas ne
pas juger
ils doivent prendre des décisions ils
doivent choisir quelles réponses seront
mises en avant
or pour des sujets complexes comme la
pollution du nucléaire mais aussi la
pertinence des mesures de confinement ou
la gestion de la dette publique
il n'y a malheureusement pas de réponse
simple répondre oui ou non à la question
le nucléaire paul utile sera
nécessairement ne simplification
radicale gênante expliqué la pollution
du nucléaire nécessite des minutes voire
des heures de discussions mais alors
dans cette discussion il faudra
commencer quelque part et le simple
choix du point de départ sachant
notamment l'attention limitée du public
sera nécessairement un dilemme délicat
alors bien sûr la plupart du temps les
dixièmes de recommandations auxquelles
les algorithmes sont confrontés ne sont
pas des questions de vie ou de mort mais
parfois quand il s'agit de recherche sur
les vaccins sur le coït 19 ou sur la
santé mentale
il s'agit bel et bien de question de vie
ou de mort et comme il y à 2 milliards
de telles recherches auxquelles il faut
répondre même si seulement un pour cent
de ces requêtes sont des questions de
vie ou de mort
on obtient alors des millions de dilemme
éthique majeur
pire encore quand il s'agit d'influencer
les préférences de l'opinion publique
sur les énergies dans lesquels nos
gouvernements vont investir
il s'agit bel et bien de question de vie
ou de mort non seulement pour les
utilisateurs influencé par les
algorithmes de recommandations mais de
façon plus vicieuse encore ce sont des
questions de vie ou de mort pour des
millions de concitoyens des utilisateurs
de ces moteurs de recherche
en effet l'organisation mondiale de la
santé estime que la pollution de l'air
tue autour de 4 millions d'humains par
an les meilleurs choix énergétiques
pourraient permettre de réduire cette
pollution
et même si l'effet n'est que de 1% ceci
reviendrait à sauver ou à sacrifier des
dizaines de milliers de vies ce qui
semble d'ailleurs déjà plus grand que le
nombre total de morts causées par
l'énergie
clay m plus que jamais elle est devenue
critique de cesser de voir les dilemmes
des algorithmes de recommandations comme
étant un problème individuel dans le
monde ultra connectés dans lequel on vit
ce qui est recommandé à vos voisins
affecte désormais la santé et la
sécurité de tous vos concitoyens et de
leurs proches
surtout quand il s'agit de maladies
contagieuses comme le colis de 10,9 de
décisions politiques qui vont affecter
l'économie et l'environnement ou de
risques de sécurité nationale comme la
radicalisation idéologique votre
bien-être et votre sécurité dépend de ce
qui sera massivement recommandé à
d'autres l'éthique des algorithmes une
recommandation n'est pas un dilemme
individuel c'est un dilemme de société
l'exemple introductif de cette vidéo est
toutefois etc
un moment trompeur j'ai donné une
importance disproportionnée aux
résultats de recherche
cependant ces résultats de recherche
représente une fraction de plus en plus
faible de la manière dont les
algorithmes influence les utilisateurs
et ça c'est particulièrement le cas dans
le cas de google
en effet depuis 2016 à chaque instant il
est en fait plus de vues sur youtube que
de recherche sur google avec en 2019
un total de 1000 yards heures de
visionnage par jour pour 2 milliards
d'utilisateurs humain mais ce nombre a
certainement exploser en 2020 avec la
pandémie kobe de 10,9 et les
restrictions de circulation mais surtout
de vue sur trois sur youtube sont le
résultat de recommandations de
l'algorithme de youtube deux fois sur
trois les utilisateurs voient une vidéo
parce que l'algorithme leur a recommandé
de voir cette vidéo
et ça c'est youtube sur d'autres réseaux
sociaux comme facebook twitter ou
linkedin
les news feed sont certainement un lieu
central de la consommation de contenus
or ces news feed qui sont ceux à quoi
les utilisateurs sont exposées lors ce
qu'ils ouvrent leur téléphone a appuyé
sur les applications de youtube facebook
twitter ou linkedin cnued tweets sont
confectionnés par des algorithmes de
recommandations extrêmement sophistiqué
qui vont sélectionner quel contenu
montrer à quels utilisateurs parmi les
millions ou milliards de contenu à leur
disposition de nos jours la majorité du
temps les utilisateurs ne vont pas
chercher l'information l'information
laure est servi sur un plateau par un
serveur de contenu et même si en
principe bien sûr les utilisateurs
peuvent protester et changé de serveur
en pratique la quasi totalité des
utilisateurs ne font que consommer ce
que les serveurs leur met dans
l'assiette qu'il s'agisse d'informations
de qualité ou de résultat de campagnes
de désinformation organisée dès lors le
serveur a un pouvoir énorme
il peut décider de l'information que
boufferont à longueur de journée des
milliards d'humains sur terre
voilà une situation unique dans
l'histoire dans l'histoire de l'humanité
jamais aucune entité on a eu un tel
pouvoir
et comme le dirait l'oncle de spider man
de grand pouvoir implique de grandes
responsabilités
pour bien se rendre compte de l'étendue
du pouvoir des algorithmes de
recommandation il est critique de bien
mesurer l'ampleur de leur influence sur
la population
malheureusement la grande difficulté de
cela c'est que contrairement au crash
d'un avion les catastrophes causées par
les algorithmes de recommandations ne
correspondent pas à quelques événements
spectaculaires qui vont faire la une des
journaux l'influencent monumentale des
algorithmes recommandations correspond
davantage un très grand nombre de
petites contributions à des catastrophes
pour utiliser le jargon des
mathématiciens chaque recommandation
davantage bénéfique va voir un tout
petit effet epsilon cependant ces
recommandations ou lieu un très grand
nombre n 2 fois du coup l'effet cumulé
de toutes ces recommandations est en
première approximation de l'ordre de
haine fois epsilon malheureusement de
telles quantités sont très difficiles à
conceptualiser pour nous autres humains
car nous avons souvent une très mauvaise
intuition des très grands et des très
petit nombre
une simple règle de trois toutefois nous
aider à nous rendre compte de l'ampleur
de telles nombre est d'à quel point
notre intuition est un très mauvais
guide pour les appréhender
ainsi les quelques os et elon musk de
notre monde ont une fortune estimée à
des centaines de milliards de dollars
clairement c'est beaucoup mais à quel
point est-ce beaucoup et bien on peut
comparer cela à quelqu'un que moi dont
la fortune est de l'ordre de la dizaine
de milliers de dollars
en calculant simplement le rapport entre
leur fortune est la mienne on obtient un
rapport 10 millions et ça c'est énorme
par exemple à titre personnel quand je
vois une pièce de 10 centimes par terre
je me dit généralement que ça ne vaut
pas la peine que j'aille la ramasser ces
n'augmenteraient ma fortune personnelle
que d'un cent mille yens mais
proportionnellement ça veut dire que
c'est jeff bezos a le même dédain que
moi pour un cent millième de sa fortune
ça voudrait dire que s'il voit un chèque
d'un million d'euros traîner par terre
jeff bezos ce ne prendrait pas la peine
de se baisser pour le ramasser
pour jeff bezos ce un million de dollars
c'est littéralement ce qu'est un pilote
pour moi une cacahuète de la même façon
quand il s'agit d'algorithmes de
recommandations qui affecte des
milliards d'humains
les exemples qui nous sont familiers
sont en fait extrêmement trompeurs
pour bien mesurer l'ampleur de l'impact
de ces algorithmes les critiques de
prendre le temps de faire des calculs
plutôt que de se fier à notre intuition
mais donc quel est le nombre grands
thèmes de recommandations que font ces
algorithmes
combien de dilemme ses algorithmes
ont-ils été confrontés eh bien on a vu
que youtube en 2010 neuf c'est environ 5
millions de vues par minute
or le taux de clics par impression est
de l'ordre de quelques pourcents disons
2%
autrement dit on va supposer ici qu'une
vidéo doit être recommandé 50 fois pour
faire une vue ça voudrait dire que le
nombre de recommandations par minute est
en fait 50 x 5 millions soit 250
millions à l'échelle de leur ça nous
fait 60 x 250 millions soit 15 milliards
de recommandation chaque jour cela fait
24 x 15 milliards soit 360 milliards et
chaque année ça ne fait 365 x 360
milliards ce qui nous donne 130 mille
milliards de recommandation ici on
regarde maintenant ce qui s'est passé
depuis maintenant plus d'une décennie
et si on inclut aussi les
recommandations sur facebook et les
autres réseaux sociaux on obtient un
chiffre qui s'approche du million de
milliards le nombre de dilemme auquel
les algorithmes de recommandations ont
été confrontés et auquel ils vont être
confrontés dans les années à venir est
de l'ordre du million de milliards
ce nombre est absolument car quand tu es
ce qu il est dit mille fois plus que la
fortune de bidos musk en dollars
si seulement 1 pour mille de ces
dilemmes est une question de vie ou de
mort par exemple parce qu'il parle de
vaccins de pollution de suicide
cela nous fait déjà des milliers de
milliards de dilemme sur des questions
de vie ou de mort
beaucoup de discussions sur
gensse artificielle cherche à comparer
les humains aux machines cependant ces
discussions ça tarde souvent sur des
tâches ponctuelles comme gagner au jeu
de go conduire une voiture autonome ou
avoir une discussion avec un humain et
toutes ces comparaisons omettre les deux
propriétés les plus importantes des
algorithmes et plus sophistiqués
d'aujourd'hui à savoir d'un côté le fait
que les applications les plus lucratives
et les plus influentes de ses
algorithmes ne sont pas ces tâches
ponctuelles et de l'autre le fait que
les algorithmes ne surpasse déjà très
très très très largement dans la
répétition des tâches les algues au
rythme se prêtent beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus que les humains à ce que
les anglophones appellent la sq et
mobility qu'on pourrait traduire par la
mise à l'échelle
vu les échelles des mesures et
d'internet cette capacité de mise à
l'échelle semble en fait critique pour
surveiller les réseaux sociaux modérer
les faux comptes et recommander des
contenus de qualité
en effet pour bien se rendre compte je
vous invite à vous demander quel est le
nombre d'heures d'une nouvelle vidéo
mise en ligne sur youtube
à chaque heure quelle est l'ampleur du
flux de nouveaux contenus sur youtube
combien d'humains en simultané il
faudrait pour regarder tout ce qui est
mise en ligne sur youtube
d'après vous on a combien à quelques
heures de nouvelles vidéos par heure à
quelques centaines d'heures et bien en
le nombre d'heures de nouveaux contenus
par heure était égal à 30 milles chaque
heure trente mille heures de vidéos sont
mises en ligne sur youtube
et encore une fois c'était en 2019 et ça
a certainement exploser depuis trente
mille heures de nouvelles vidéos par
heure sur la fédé milliards d'heures de
vidéos au total rien contexte ça
représente des proportions
gargantuesques
à titre personnel je dis environ dix
mille mots par heure il y aurait donc de
l'ordre de milliers de milliards de mots
sur youtube
sachant qu'un livre contient cent mille
mots environ youtube représente alors 10
millions de livres ou dit autrement rien
contexte du tube c'est environ mille
fois tout wikipédia or pour modérer la
plateforme youtube doit aussi gérer les
droits d'auteur déterminer l'éligibilité
aux annonceurs détecter la pédophilie
sous-titré les vidéos est identifié à
qui ces contenus devraient être
recommandé à chaque heure
youtube doit avoir analysé ces trente
mille heures de
compte-tenu sachant en plus que ce
travail de modération est traumatisant
pour des modérateurs humain et que ces
modérateurs humains aussi leur propre
biais notamment sur des sujets comme le
nucléaire et qu'il aurait difficile de
parfaitement comprendre et appliquer la
politique de modération de youtube on se
rend vite compte que la tâche de rendre
les réseaux sociaux peiné fiq ne pourra
pas se passer des algorithmes
malheureusement concevoir des
algorithmes qui serait robustement
bénéfique pour cette tâche et surtout
vérifier que ses algorithmes ont
effectivement robustement bénéfique
c'est une tâche extrêmement ardue on
sait par exemple que pour avoir des
algorithmes performant dans cette tâche
il va falloir les entrées sur d'énormes
quantités de données hors de la même
façon que youtube ne peut pas être lue
par un humain ni même par un groupe
d'humains
les algorithmes entraîné sur de telles
quantités de données massives et dont le
nombre de paramètres se comptent
également en milliards pouvoir en
milliers de milliards
ces algorithmes échappe désormais
complètement à la simple lecture par des
ingénieurs ou des armées d'ingénieurs de
leur code
si on veut espérer résoudre les millions
de milliards de dilemmes éthiques qu'il
faut résoudre pour rendre les réseaux
sociaux bénéfique
il va nous falloir investir massivement
dans la conception le test et
l'amélioration des algorithmes de
recommandations les plus sophistiqués
d'aujourd'hui tel est le fabuleux
chantier dont elle m'a dit andy et moi
parlons dans notre livre et dont on va
parler dans cette série elle est
également le défi monumental que cherche
à relever la plateforme tournesol que
des collègues et moi avons conçu et qui
est accessible sur tous nos sols point
ap
et si vous aimerez en savoir plus sur
tournesol ça tombe bien dans les
prochaines vidéos
je vais vous en parler et même beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup vous en parler